I’m always cold, so I always have a sweater
on or near by.
But as I shiver through the chilly California
winter, I wonder, does my furry friend need
a sweater too?
With all that fur, you would think dogs and
cats have natural insulation and I mean sweaters
look pretty silly, so are they necessary?
Just like people, tolerance to cold varies
from dog to dog, some breeds might have more
insulating fat, some might have denser fur.
But no dog can withstand winter weather with
the exceptions of some breeds like the sheepdog,
Chow Chow, St. Bernards, and Huskies.
Huskies are especially built for the cold.
They double up their fur to stay warm.
The undercoat is soft and fluffy for insulation
while the top coat is coarser and protects
the undercoat from ice and snow buildup.
They can live and work in temperatures as
low as 75 degrees BELOW ZERO.
A Newfoundland might not need an extra layer
either, they grow out hair in locks, which
provides another natural layer of warmth.
So much so, they don’t mind swimming in
near freezing temps!
On the other hand, smaller, lighter dog breeds
might need some help as they usually have
less body fat.
Dogs with shorter hair dogs like chihuahuas
and older dogs that struggle more to maintain
their body temperature probably need an extra
layer.
Listen to your pet.
If they seem hesitant to go do their business
in the cold, try bundling them up.
If you live in an especially snowy area, a
buildup of ice or snow can cause some nasty
abrasions on their feet.
Try some booties which help protect their
paws, plus you might get some good Vines out
of your dog prancing in their boots.
They look like such nerds.
Cats can get cold more easily than dogs actually.
Their body temperatures run hot, while we’re
98.1 degrees, cats run a toasty 101.5.
This means their range of comfy temperatures
is 20 degrees hotter than ours, their thermoneutral
zone ranges from 86 to 97 degrees.
Most houses seem pretty chilly to cats at
just 73.4 degrees.
So it doesn’t take winter weather for them
to feel cold.
Cats can be pretty fussy, so a feline sweater
is probably not the best option.
Boxes are best.
It’s no secret cats like boxes, I’m looking
at you Maru, they make them feel safer by
giving them a place to hide, but it also keeps
them warm.
Corrugated cardboard is an especially good
insulator, so there’s no need to buy a fancy
cat pod, just check your recycle bin!
On the extreme end of things, severe cold
can be deadly for pets - just like it is for
humans.
If left in the cold too long, dogs and cats
risk hyperthermia, especially if their coats
get wet.
They expend too much energy in keeping warm
and their blood pressure drops dangerously.
Which might lead to cardiac arrest.
So getting back to our original question:
does your pet need a sweater?
Depends on the dog, depends on the temperature.
Small dogs, dogs with little fur, or elderly
dogs, yeah. they could use one.
But it also depends on the sweater, I mean
if it’s an especially adorable sweater.
OF COURSE they need it.
So please don’t leave your pets out in the
winter, if you do, provide them with adequate
shelter.
There’s a link below that tells you how
to do just that.
What do you think?
Would you put your pooch in a sweater?
Or is it silly?
Let us know in the comments below.
Hit the subscribe and check back every day
for more DNews.